이 방법은 Boolean circuit으로
꽤 직접적으로 표현할 수 있어요.
한 가지 방법은 두 개의 1비트 정수를 더하는 작은 circuit부터 시작하는 거예요.
그러면 0에서 2 사이의 숫자가 나오는데,
덜 중요한 비트는 입력 비트들의 XOR이고
더 중요한 비트, 즉 올림 비트는 두 입력 비트의 AND예요.
이 두 연산을 함께 수행하는 circuit을
반가산기라고 부르기도 해요.
입력 비트가 두 개뿐일 때는
잘 작동하지만, 각각 1비트 이상인 정수를 더하려면
올림 비트를 어떻게든
처리해야 해요.
그래서 할 수 있는 건 두 개의 반가산기를
직렬 연결하고 생성되는 올림 비트의 OR을 취해서
전가산기라는 걸 만드는 거예요.
이건 기본적으로 세 개의 1비트
숫자를 더하는 Boolean circuit이에요.
전가산기가 있으면, 가장 덜 중요한 비트부터
가장 중요한 비트까지 직렬 연결해서 숫자를 더할 수 있어요.
기본적으로 전가산기를 사용해서 올림 비트를 처리하면서
표준 덧셈 알고리즘을 구현하는 거예요.
이 계산의 비용은 얼마일까요?
각 XOR gate에 7개의 기본
gate가 필요하니까 반가산기에는 10개의 gate가 필요하고
따라서 전가산기에는 21개의 gate가 필요해요. 반가산기 두 개에 OR gate 하나니까요.
결국, 입력 숫자가 모두 N비트라면, 가장 덜 중요한 비트에
반가산기 하나가 필요하고
나머지 모든 비트에 전가산기가 필요해서, 최종 결과는 21 곱하기 N 빼기 1 더하기 10, 즉 총 21N 빼기 11개의 gate예요.
만약 어떤 이유로 FANOUT gate를 세지 않고
XOR gate를 gate 집합에 포함시키기로 하면
총 5N 빼기 3개의 gate가 필요해요.
정수 덧셈 같은 다양한 계산을 수행하는 데 정확히 몇 개의 gate나 기본 연산이 필요한지 아는 건 좋은 일이에요.
방금 정수 덧셈에서 본 것처럼요.
물론 이 계산들을 실제로 구현하려면 이런 세부사항을 알아야 해요.
하지만 특히 더 복잡한 알고리즘에 대해 항상 이 정도로 자세하게 들어가면,
세부사항에 금방 파묻히게 될 거예요.
많은 경우에 부차적인
중요성을 가진 세부사항에요.
알고리즘 분석에서 매우 흔한 일을
단순화하는 한 가지 방법은 빅-O 표기법을 사용하는 거예요.
이를 통해 성장률을 꽤 간단하고
매우 편리한 방식으로 표현하고 비교할 수 있어요.
여기 이 표기법의 기반이 되는 정의를 볼 수 있어요.
두 함수 G와 H가 있다고 가정해요.
간단하게 비음수 정수 값을 취한다고 생각할 수 있지만
실제로 꼭 그래야 하는 건 아니에요. G와 H가 예를 들어 다른 계산의 비용을 나타낸다고 할 수 있어요.
그러면 G가 H의 빅-O라고 말하는데, 이건 전통적으로
이렇게 등호로 써요.
N이 충분히 크기만 하면 G(N)이
어떤 양의 상수 C 곱하기 H(N) 이하인 경우에요.
이건 N이 커질 때
무슨 일이 일어나는지에 관한 거예요.
형식적으로, 충분히 크다는 것은 어떤 N_0의 선택이 있어서 N이 최소 N_0일 때마다
부등식이 참이라는 뜻이에요.
핵심은 이 숫자들 C와
N_0가 고정되어 있다는 거예요.
어떤 숫자든 될 수 있지만,
어떤 숫자든 N이 커져도 변하면 안 돼요.
이런 종류의 정의를 처음 보시면
익숙해지는 데 시간이 좀 걸릴 수 있고, 이 개념을
이 강의보다 훨씬 더 자세하게
설명하는 자료를 찾을 수 있어요.
보통 우리가 하는 건 함수 G가 얼마나 빨리 커지는지에 대한
무언가를 표현하기 위해 함수 H를 간단하게 선택하는 거예요.
예를 들어, 17 곱하기 N의 세제곱 빼기 257
곱하기 N의 제곱 더하기 65,537인 함수는
N의 세제곱의 빅-O이고, 이 예시를 정의에 맞출 수 있어요.
C와 N_0를 적절히 선택하면요.
예를 들어, C를 18로 잡으면 N이 충분히 크기만 하면
그 표현식이 실제로 18 곱하기 N의 세제곱 이하가 돼요.
이 표기법을 정수 덧셈 예시에
다시 연결하면, 비음수 정수를 더하기 위한 Boolean circuit의 패밀리가 존재해서
N번째 circuit, 즉 길이 N의 입력에 대해 작동하는 것의 크기가
N의 빅-O라고 말할 수 있어요. 우리 분석에 따른
CN의 실제 크기는 21 곱하기 N 빼기 11이었지만,
그건 N의 빅-O예요.
이렇게 세부사항을 버리는 게 항상 현명한 건 아니지만, 여기서는 말이 돼요.
표준 덧셈 알고리즘의 본질적인 성격을 드러내 주니까요. 비용이 더하는 숫자의 크기에
선형적으로 증가한다는 거예요.
이 표현은 정확히 어떤 gate를 기본 연산으로 보는지 같은
모델의 저수준 세부사항에 민감하지 않아요.
예를 들어요.
예를 들어, XOR gate를 기본 연산으로 간주하거나 FANOUT gate를
gate로 세지 않기로 하거나 둘 다 해도
정수 덧셈이 N의 빅-O 비용으로 계산될 수 있다는 건 변하지 않아요.